foreign
[Music]
s and illustrations from the forthcoming
Pixar movie Elemental were disclosed to
a hall crowded with multitudes of Disney
fans during Walt Disney Studios
showpiece at the d23 Expo the motivation
behind the movie directed by Peter Stone
and developed by Denise Reem just like
the good dinosaur is a narrative of
immigrants trying to pursue their
fantasies in magnificent communities
where language and civilizations make
contact it was officially stated that
Elemental will come to terms with the
basic elements of the world as the title
indicates fire water land and air will
play a vital role in the tale living
side by side in one world Peterson has
already provided the voices for many
legendary Pixar protagonists For example
most recently he was Sox's voice in
Pixar's light year Elemental is of one
of a kind movie clearly influenced by
sone's Family background in New York my
parents were immigrants from Korea in
the 1970s and opened a healthy and
growing convenience store in the Bronx
the director simply explained we were
among the many households who made the
journey to a new territory with dreams
and aspirations all of us melding within
one big bowl of cultural contacts
language groups and lovely little
neighborhood conditions that is what
helped bring me to Elemental the story
appears to follow an improbable Ensemble
Ember and Wade threw a big city where
citizens of fire water land and air
exist side by side the Ferocious young
lady and the enjoyable gushy go with the
flow dude are going to explore something
foundational how very much they have in
common while much information is not yet
revealed Ember and wait the central
protagonist will be voiced by Leah Lewis
and Mamadou Athey respectively the
film's visual effects and entertainment
style are breathtaking this film does
not not closely resemble any other Pixar
creation the footage displayed was not
even entirely completed animation most
of it was still very much in extremely
rough and unresolved form and others
were an animated short form Pixar's
filmmakers appear to be trying to push
themselves like never before to develop
the setting and fictional characters of
this plotline Elemental does seem to be
an extremely sentimental deeply moving
and culturally significant Pixar movie
Elemental will be released on June 16
2023 at the event Disney affirmed that
Elemental would be launched in theaters
when it debuts verifying that Pixar
Motion Pictures will be once more big
screen memories
[Music]
thank you